welcome welcome to tomorrow's national
stem day a time to encourage kids
especially girls to explore science
technology engineering and math the
truth is women are grossly
underrepresented in stem fields we make
up half the U.S Workforce but only 27
percent of stem workers but we are
making progress y'all 50 years ago it
was only eight percent so
back with another stem experiment you
can try at home as Philip cook better
known as Kim teacher Phil Give It Up
great to see you again great to see you
as well thanks for having me absolutely
we love you okay so why is Sim so
important for all kids I think we want
the best for our kids right we want to
prepare them for what they're going to
see in their life ahead when they become
adults yeah and I think for them they
need to be problem solvers and critical
thinkers so stem activities that we can
do with them at an early age help set
the stage for them to be successful yeah
that Foundation I like that so wait what
are we learning today I'm straight so
today we're going to be do doing an
experiment it's all about the s in stem
okay we're going to be doing a science
experiment and it's a pretty simple
experiment that you guys can do at home
as well to celebrate tomorrow which is
going to be National stem day and you
just need three things so you're going
to need a microwave like this you will
need some paper which we've got paper up
here and a pilot friction pen which has
special thermosensitive ink oh I'm sorry
the go-to erasable pen of the Kelly
Clarkson show is that is that what we
were talking about is that we're talking
about they're great pens
um how do we no I actually they're the
go-to pen in my class too my kids love
them I actually love them I'm so stoked
partner so how do we use them in the
experiment so what we're going to be
doing is an experiment where we learn
about microwaves like how a microwave
works so we're going to be using the ink
which will disappear when it when it's
heated to be able to tell us where it's
hot and where it's not in a microwave
because believe it or not microwaves
don't do the best job of evenly heating
Foods you will know this if you've ever
had a frozen burrito and you stick it in
the microwave and one is one part's
Frozen and the other parts like molten
lava this is like my childhood with Hot
Pockets yeah absolutely yeah absolutely
you burn your tongue on the outside and
then in the middle I'm like how is this
still ice I don't know yeah but one of
your stage hands uh Marcel he's made a
great picture he's so talented yeah look
at that I love that he made Angry Blake
so he he used pilot friction pens for
this yeah so what we're going to see
hopefully is wherever this part of the
paper gets hot the thermosensitive ink
is going to disappear okay and we're
just gonna see what that looks like okay
Marcel you're so gifted God you can draw
so well we saw him on okay yeah he's
incredible okay so we're putting it in
there yeah okay and it doesn't take long
so when you're doing this at home just
okay I want to take the tray out okay
we've already done that I kind of
noticed that and I was like are you
missing something or else you kind of
ruined oh I get it I get it I get it
let's see how much a Blake is left
prediction how to make Blake disappear
I've been working on this experiment for
years okay
here we go
oh my gosh it's just ahead of hair yeah
so
here's what's interesting about that
you can see there's some spots where
there's still clearly ink that's where
it didn't get hot enough yeah and if you
think about it like this you see Hot
Spot cold spot hotspot cold spot well if
you know that a microwave is a wave it
kind of goes like this the high part of
the wave and the low part of the wave
those are what make the molecules in
food like the fat the protein the water
yeah the jiggle and when they kind of
hit against one another that translates
into heat so here they got hot here they
were not I love that okay but now this
is without the tray okay so now we can
actually see white has to be in there
okay so we're going to take this part
out we'll take in that okay and we're
going to put the tray back in and see
why most microwave ovens have to have
something that rotates the food
are we making him completely disappear
this is the best magic ever no spoilers
we'll let it go for about uh 20 10 or
15. well I set it for 20 but week of the
week we might take it out okay what do
you think is going to happen
in my heart yeah
I think he's just gonna be gone all of
them yeah okay and then I'm gonna send
it to him
okay wait there's something else that's
cool about this ink okay you can cool it
down and make the ink come back I'll
show you that here who needs to do that
I'm just kidding I'm just kidding now if
you look oh my gosh a lot more of it's
going can we talk about that two pages
hanging on right now like that's like
that's crazy so this is the reason why
when you're using a microwave that you
want to make sure the food's on the
edges so if you put a plate of spaghetti
in here it's going to be nice and warmed
up here but right here near the toupee
yeah that's where it's going to be icy
cold okay yeah
okay how do you make it are you gonna
make it come back I think we should Okay
so
it relies upon temperature okay not to
make it disappear we're gonna make it
really cold now if you're at home and
you try this experiment you could try it
by just sticking in the freezer for a
little bit okay and the coldness of the
freezer will make the ink come back but
we're going to use
oh I need because I'm a chemistry
teacher we're going to use something a
little bit more intense this is where we
look really hot man yeah this is where
it turned on America right now this is
right
hi
pilot friction erasable go to kind of
the Kelly Clarkson show
let's get some dry ice in here solid
carbon dioxide which is really cold
about negative 79 Celsius totally
negative 110 Fahrenheit I knew that I
was just making sure you did so it was a
quiz yeah yeah so we're just gonna dump
some okay try not get you with it okay
on top of Blake okay we're gonna let it
sit for a second we're dumping on Blake
okay
the greatest episode
[Laughter]
it does start to come back it's starting
to come back so we see him starting to
come back
[Applause]
[Music]
use our hand and warm it up he's all
happy playing guitar man look at that
back to normal God's country back there
you go thank you so
much
this is so cool I love science it is it
is cool
be sure to follow him on Tick Tock at
Kim teacher Phil and check out Kelly
clarksonshow.com for more friction
experiments you can try on National stem
day
[Music]
thank you foreign
[Applause]
[Music]